بدلاً من استبدال المشي ، ماذا لو تمكنا
من زيادة المشي أو تحسينه ،
فهذه ليست أحذية تزلج على الجليد ، فهي عبارة عن زلاجات على
سطح القمر تم تصميمها بواسطة روبوتات التحول ، وهي شركة
ناشئة من مختبر الروبوتات في
جامعة كارنيجي ميلون ، أعتقد أن
المشكلة الأكبر هي أن المشي
بطيء جدًا ، إنه غير فعال للغاية
للتجول عن طريق المشي ، فبدلاً من
استبدال المشي ، ماذا لو
أمكنك معرفة زيادة المشي أو تحسينه ،
تقول الشركة إن هذه الأحذية التي تعمل بالبطارية
يمكن أن تزيد من سرعات المشي حتى سبعة
أميال في الساعة باستخدام
خوارزمية التعلم الآلي ، تقول الروبوتات أن الأحذية
يمكن أن تتكيف معها  نمط المشي الخاص بالمستخدم في
الوقت الفعلي الذي تعرفه على الرغم من أنه يحتوي على
بعض عناصر التزلج على الجليد ، فأنت لا تقوم مطلقًا
بالتحرك بحرية ، بل تتحرك فقط
عندما تريد نقل السائرين على سطح القمر ، ويمكن أن
تناسب معظم الأحذية بأشرطة مرنة
يمكن ارتداؤها وخلعها بسهولة باستخدام
Magnetic  أبازيم مزودة بتقنية تحديد السرعة
وأنظمة الكبح ،
تدعي الشركة أن الأحذية آمنة للاستخدام على
الأرصفة أو  في المناطق المزدحمة
خارج التنقل الشخصي أو تشغيل
مشاهد الأخطاء ، نعتقد أنها
ستكون رائعة في مراكز التوزيع ،
متاجر السوبر ماركت مثل المستودعات على
سبيل المثال حيث لا تكون مؤتمتة بالكامل
ولكنها لا تزال تتطلب الكثير من الأشخاص الذين
يتجولون حول روبوتات التحول ، كما
يزعمون أن المستخدمين يمكنهم  المشي أكثر من ستة
أميال بعد شحنة واحدة لمدة
ساعة ونصف تقول الشركة إنها
ستسلم الدفعة الأولى من الأحذية
للمستهلكين في مارس 2023 بما يقرب من
أربعة عشر مائة دولار وأعتقد أنه في
يوم من الأيام ستعرف بمجرد أن نحقق
المقاييس الاقتصادية سنكون كذلك  قادرين على خفض السعر ،
سنكون قادرين على تطوير موديلات أحدث
ستسمح لنا في النهاية بتخفيض أسعار السيارات